- That little A and
At?
See, that's what I said.
Mm-hm.
Um, Katie said she
thought it was "about."
Yeah.
Oh.
MAN: But I'd never heard it.
KATIE COURIC: Or
around or about.
MAN: I'd never heard it said.
I'd always seen the mark
but never heard it said.
Yeah.
What is internet anyway?
KATIE COURIC: What do
you say to that, Allison?
MAN: What, do you
write to it, like mail?
No, a lot of people
use it and communicate.
I guess it's becoming
really big now.
But Allison, can you
explain what internet is?
My name is Darrin.
I'm an investment banker.
In the mid-'90s, Wall
Street has finally
got a new favorite super model.
[beeping]
[dial-up tones]
Silicon Valley!
One word-- "Netscape."
Netscape?
They have zero concept
of what Netscape is.
They don't even know
what the internet is.
Pixelon is number one
in internet broadcasting.
theglobe.com?
It's a social network.
People will want to log on.
I guarantee.
It's very addictive.
[phone ringing]
OK, let me break it down for
you in the simplest of terms.
This is the beginning of what
they call the browser wars.
NASDAQ is pumping.
Why don't we have a price?
Refresh your page.
$71 a share?
You got to be--
are you kiddin' me?
[cheers]
It's the biggest
IPO since Microsoft.
I'm going to liven
things up a little bit.
[beatboxes]
People are going to
be throwing money at us.
[pop]
We are going to be very
wealthy and very famous!
We are the top
browser in the business.
Congratulations.
[tired cheers]
It also makes us a target.
[gun cocks]
[gunshot]
[casing clinks]
Microsoft owns the internet.
Did they just threaten us?
I'm going to bring
in a couple of experts.
Netscape changed the game.
We were at Microsoft's mercy.
We were the new
kid on the block.
They were deathbed
competitors.
[bubble pops]
So that happened.
We're out of money.
What about the
technology I created?
Goddammit!
[inaudible].
Pixelon was a joke.
MAN: We have 90% of
the browser market.
You've also got Microsoft
breathing down your neck.
Good talk.
I created something that
you all now use every day.
You're welcome.
"Get big fast" was the mantra.
We are running a
billion-dollar company.
They wanted to
take it on the train
even though they didn't know
where the train was going.
People are hoping for--
--a better tomorrow.
[cheers]
MAN: And that's
what we are selling.
So let's keep it up!
[shouting]
[ringing and beeping]